this series is brought to you by Globe
planets welcome back to part five where
we are diving deep in to lighting so
with twin motion you basically have a
series of different lighting Available
to You predominantly external and
internal Lighting in the last episode we
discussed all of the planting
Landscaping of course thanks to Glow
plants for sponsoring the video but
today we are specifically talking about
the actual lighting because we did
briefly discuss the ambience and also
the global lighting features in our last
video I will dive into interior lighting
in this tutorial so let's break it down
and let's make it super simple if we fly
into any one of our rooms let's start
with the master bedroom because it is by
far the easiest space to light we can do
Lighting in a number of ways first of
all we actually want to make sure that a
lighting appears on the ceiling so we
can do that by going into sketchfab and
searching potentially for something like
a Down light once some options appear
you might be able to download something
that looks like this that's probably a
little bit too detailed for lights so as
an alternative what we can also do is go
back into our library go to our objects
go to our Primitives and then start with
a base Circle if I simply click once
click OK Escape out of that select our
base Circle and reduce the size by 0.1
and by 0.1 again we're going to get a
very small down light sized object
now it's up to you guys if you want to
have it only as one object or if you
want to duplicate that once more so if I
was to duplicate this drag it down a
tiny bit let's go copy spacing point one
is okay
and then resize Again by 0.9 you'll see
that we've created two identical base
circles now we can drop them both in to
this ceiling and drop one lower than the
other for best practice I like to move
them off just a little bit go to my
metals and then drag and drop my brushed
metal just on to the back layer so then
that way we can change that to a nice
black aluminum base go back to materials
scroll down to the bottom to Neons and
drag Neon 2 onto the smaller base Circle
we created in that instance we can
realign our base circles together now we
have one black base Circle and one
glowing light if we wanted to continue
reducing that in size until we were
relatively happy with the down light we
could and it makes something along those
lines
what we would then want to do is hold
Ctrl shift or any way you want to select
both of these objects in our scene right
click and then we want to create a new
subcontainer that sub container is going
to be called down white simply Drag and
Drop the Base circle into the down light
from there on in and that way you can
toggle on and off your downlight in one
go in order to move those elements we do
need to select those base circles again
so let's select That Base Circle once
I'm going to put two down lights
directly in front of the bed so let's
fly back around to the underside of the
bed and then duplicate by holding shift
a secondary down light pressing Ok We're
happy with that drag and dropping it
back into down lights so we can group
them and toggle them on and off as we
need we can select all of our elements
and realign once again as we see fit so
I'm genuinely happy with the position of
those two down lights it looks a little
bit odd but bear with me for the moment
we are going to get a little bit more
creative with this down light design
next we we want to come into our library
we then want to go into our lights panel
which is what the predominant focus of
this video is
now inside twin motion you have a series
of different lighting Styles and all of
these cast different shadows cast
different lights and cast different
glows so it's up to you where and how
you wish to use them and what they're
being used for to keep things relatively
generic and simple let's go with either
just the generic Spotlight or pick any
one of these and keep it consistent for
this download type personally I think
this ies7 looks relatively nice so I'm
going to drag it and I'm going to click
it over each one of my downlights that
I've created next I'm going to make sure
they are dragged into my download lights
folder again so I can make life simple
for me to turn them on and off and just
flying around you'll see that down light
is relatively bright even in the daytime
now of course if we click into one of
our light sources we get a new menu and
we get an abundance of different
settings to change now of course twin
motion is overwhelming in this sense and
there's a lot to learn so don't feel
overwhelmed just simply go through this
step by step it is quite
self-explanatory first of all light
enabled or disabled so ticking that box
will either turn the light on or off
next you'll see the intensity at 300
lumens now from the get-go 300 lumens
might seem like an excessive amount but
if you actually dive into Google and
bring up any of these downlight Lumen
charts a six to nine watt LED down light
which is basically every single down
light you can buy roughly at anywhere
from six all the way through to 12 watts
is 450 through to 800 lumens at the
moment we've got our set to 300 so if we
bump that up to 450 do the same for the
secondary light
we can then move on and I'll explain how
this works once we turn our lights down
attenuation is basically a very fancy
way of saying how far is the light being
pushed from the down light to the ground
in this instance we have approximately
three meter ceilings so we can reduce
that to three meters and you will see
that the intensity of the light isn't
being pushed through the floor if we
increase it to 10 meters it's throwing
that light much stronger
for a much further distance so 2.7
ceilings three meter ceilings will give
you a more realistic you can see these
four yellow lines shooting around the
sides of the LED light and that is
talking about the coat of angle how far
across it spreads the actual light
generally it's a little bit under 180
degrees so 160 is perfect for a down
light if you have a sphere that's
illuminated it'll be obviously 360 and
doing a whole lot more whereas for these
little lights 160 is perfectly fine if
you need a change of both of the lights
at the same time you can hold shift
select both the lights and then adjust
the settings
simultaneously if you've created a copy
moving further down we have our
temperature and our color this one is a
downright Sealy slide it down the lights
go Red Slide the slider up the lights go
white and if you Google different light
temperatures you will find exactly what
each kelvins are generally the LEDs come
in 2 800 kelvin's
4100 and 6 000 kelvins it depends how
you like your space to be lit and what
the actual end result you're looking for
so Warm Neutral and cool is a very
simple way of looking at it or you can
find some guides like this that'll
basically tell you how each space should
be used generally three and a half
thousand is a really nice Natural Glow
it makes you feel warm and comfortable I
think 3000 is too yellow for me same as
two seven so I like the three and a half
personally once you move into the four
five and six you're really getting into
the crisp bright hospital grade lights
and yes they're fantastic but they might
get a little bit clinical so three and a
half up to four you're running some
beautiful lights coming back in let's
change this back down to three and a
half thousand kelvins to get a nice warm
light
down the list you're going to have
shadows as your next check box Shadows
is again relatively simple if I come
around
and tick my Shadows box you'll see that
some additional Shadows are being cast
by this light
now the purposes of having a shadow
enabled and disabled is so that you can
actually filter more light into your
scene without having the additional
Shadows created anything from internal
lighting will create a shadow so make
sure you have that ticked for best
results whereas if you're trying to
actually increase the brightness of this
room artificially you can go for
something like an area light so we could
drag and drop an area light directly in
front of that window and once again in
front of this window
that way when we come into our bedroom
and render this image out later down the
track this entire room will be naturally
flooded with light and we won't have to
artificially enhance this image later
down the track now of course these area
lights do not cast Shadows they're left
off whereas if you tick it just a whole
bunch of chaos happens that we don't
need so we want to make sure that the
area light is off we want to semi-match
our external lighting to make sure we're
bringing more natural Lighting in for
these sorts of artificial lights six
thousand seven thousand eight thousand
depending on the actual environment
you've set up so if we went back into
our Ambience went into details we'd be
able to see that our white balance is
set to six and a half thousand which
means we could select our two area
lights change it to six and a half
thousand
and then our external area lights would
be matching our external sunlight now
that we have these two little lovely
down lights at the foot of the bed
basically providing a glow to the
walking area we could then go back into
our library go to SketchUp and type in
pendant light to see what kind of
pendant lights are available to us now
honestly sketchfab does not have the
best pendant lights it has a decent
selection of relatively basic stuff but
if you wanted something a little bit
more fancy you'd be going onto 3D sky or
any of the rendering softwares
previously mentioned maybe we want
something like this wicker basket only
that I've just noticed that it's 90
megabytes so we're not going to wait for
that to download let's get a relatively
basic glass pendant light click on that
one to download select it once click and
drag and connect it to our ceiling
once we drag it in of course we need to
scale it properly
rotate it to the correct position and
align it to our ceiling now the texture
of this light could be anything I'm not
really working on interior design at
this point in time it's more so just
teaching you the basics of twin motion
so what we do is we'd copy that light
across allow it to sit as an instance
approximately on the other Bed Head
go back to our materials drag and drop
may be a brass finish on them reduced
illuminance go back to our materials
grab the glass add a reflective glass
around so we can see what's going on and
then what we need to do is fly into our
little Globe go to lights go an
omnidirectional light make sure we're
dropping that omnidirectional light
directly into the globe itself so let's
fly back out select our omnidirectional
light adjust that ever so slightly make
sure our shadows are turned on reduce
our lighting settings and then adjust it
to the other side as well
as you notice the omnidirectional light
is going to cast the shadows in every
direction based on where you place it
however it is immediately going to light
up the scene create the shadows in the
background and make this scene come to
life at night time
now obviously during the day none of
these lights should be enabled you
shouldn't really see them the sunlight
would be more than powerful to actually
illuminate this entire space
so if we went into Ambience for example
and simply turned off auto exposure for
the purposes of this you'd see those
lights starting to come into play as in
nighttime rendering scene now those two
tiny tiny little down lights basically
play no effect from the externals but
when you go inside you've seen you'll
see they cast a nice warm glow directly
in front as does our area light so that
area light we created before if we would
turn that off you'd see quite a lot of
our illumination is gone and most of the
illumination is coming from the Sun out
the front so as you can see these area
lights provide quite a decent bit of
additional illumination without having
it to force too many lights or make them
overly bright or overly illuminated
everyone how to select our base circles
and our light fixtures we could go
around add some more lights into this
space copy them across rotate them as we
say fit so now we have two little lights
on that side of the window and we can
drag two more lights over on this side
of the actual room press ok
fly back out you'll see we have six
small lights around the perimeter of our
master bedroom these two at the very end
obviously being way way too close to
that wall because they're casting too
much of a light Shadow onto the wall so
if I was to move them away you'll see
the light being cast less and less now
don't get me wrong lights can cast
Shadows on walls and be wall washers I
just haven't created that in this
instance nor have we selected the right
area light if we wanted a wall washer
maybe we'd go something like this
ies09 so that we could push it further
away and actually wash out that wall in
nice pattern or alternatively we might
put them in the floor and rotate them
180 degrees the negative thing about
this pendant light what I've just
noticed is the fact that we don't have
the ability to add a neon texture to the
globe all of the glass is one Element so
if we wanted to add a neon Tech jar we
could go back to our library back to our
objects back to our Primitives create a
small one meter sphere reduce the sphere
significantly in size to 0.1 go to our
library our materials and add Neon 2 to
sphere now that we've got Neon 2 to the
sphere we want to illuminate it at 350
and we simply want to drag and drop it
inside the actual pendant itself
and when we have it inside the pendant
we can stretch and adjust it to slightly
suit this shape that we've got inside by
doing so we then get a more realistic
example of that Globe it's still
probably a little bit too dull but we
can work with that because it doesn't
just look like a glass wall like
obviously adjust as well by increasing
our actual glow in the Globes
and then that way it looks a lot more
realistic now if you've ever asked
yourself what is the difference between
a high quality render and an average
render you see all over Instagram well
the difference is the quality the care
and the assets that's why I've teamed up
with globe plants to be able to give you
an incredible library of the world's
best 3D photorealistic vegetation trees
shrubs and everything in between are
these Globe plans for a very long time
now you've seen them in my videos before
and finally we've come together to be
able to actually bring you a series
worthwhile so if you're looking for some
incredible 3D plants regardless of where
you are situated around the world it
doesn't matter if you're in America
Australia Africa Europe they've got all
of the plants available for every single
person around the globe so make sure you
check out Globe plants in the
description down below the link is there
for your convenience if we wanted to
create LED strip lighting as an instance
let's fly over into our kitchen
and talk about LED strip lighting now
there isn't much light going on here
just because I haven't created any so
let's go back to Ambience turn out water
exposure on so we can see what's going
on
and let's say we want to create a little
LED strip light underneath this bench
top first we'd go back into our library
we'd go lights and we'd simply select
our neon light we can drag and drop that
strip light down below Escape select our
neon light adjust our intensity again to
450 reduce our length to approximately I
believe is three meters in this bar
instance and then carefully adjust our
LED strip light until we are happy with
the position once again we want to turn
our shadows on because it is a real
light it is a working for us it is a not
working as an artificial filler and then
we can go back into Ambience turn off
our water exposure to see what that LED
strip light would look like at night
time and as you can see it's a perfect
little space filler it really
illuminates that under bench glow
and at 450 lumens it is quite strong
potentially you might want a very subtle
glow maybe 150 lumens so we can reduce
that as we see fit
now last but not least what I haven't
spoken about is inside all of these
lighting examples in the actual Library
lights part the last section is
miscellaneous if we select miscellaneous
and we're simply going to get a few
options available to us none of these
are really going to make too much of a
difference to your rendering quality
except Dusk to Dawn when you're creating
and exporting some videos
if you select Dusk to Dawn go back to
Ambience and for this to work you cannot
have a hdri sky on so I'm going to
disable my hdri sky
I'm going to turn auto exposure on and
I'm simply going to slide my time of day
Global lighting across so as the sun
beckons into this house in the afternoon
the Shadows are beautiful we get that
golden hour and then we start to go into
Dusk and this LED strip light
automatically turns on so subtle so
beautiful and as you continue to go into
the night
that LED strip light becomes more and
more prominent and more powerful anyway
Dane that's all from me I hope you've
enjoyed it so far I'm going to bring a
playlist to the side of me so if you're
joining me a little bit later you can
find all the content right here
otherwise smash that subscribe button
drop any comments in the description
down below but like always I'll see you
next Monday